HAVE A GREAT NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
WE WILL SEE YOU BACK IN NEW YORK
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE'VE GOT SOME STUNNING NEWS FOR
YOU ABOUT THE ONGOING RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
NEWS THAT WILL CHALLENGE
EVERYTHING YOU THOUGHT YOU KNEW
ABOUT THE STORY.
YESTERDAY, WE SHOW YOU THE
TERRIFYING EXTENT TO WHICH
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S SINISTER
TENDRILS HAVE ENCIRCLED THE
REPUBLIC.
RUSSIAN AGENTS ARE SO INTENT IN
UNDERMINING OUR DEMOCRACY,
THEY'VE TAKEN TO PROMOTING OUR
OWN BILL OF RIGHTS BACK TO US.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT
SPECIFICALLY.
WE ADMIT, WE AREN'T EXACTLY SURE
HOW THAT'S BAD.
BUT ADAM SCHIFF HAS ASSURED US
IT IS.
BECAUSE SCHIFF IS A PROMINENT
MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND BELIEVES
STOMACH APPEARS ON CABLE NEWS,
WE BELIEVE HIM.
TONIGHT, WE'VE LEARNED THE
FOREIGN SUBVERSION GOES DEEPER
THAN THAT.
THE RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY IS SO
SUBTLE, SO CRAFTY, SUCH A HALL
OF MIRRORS, THE PEOPLE WARNING
THE LEADERS OF THE WITCH HUNTS
ARE WITCHES.
SOUND IMPOSSIBLE?
LISTEN TO THIS.
LAST YEAR, THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE RELEASED A
DEFINITIVE REPORT ON THE RUSSIA
PRODUCT
PROPAGANDA EFFORTS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE FORCE OF THAT IS FROM THE
RUSSIAN TELEVISION CHANNEL RT,
WHICH IS RUN BY THE PUTIN
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ENGAGE IN ANTI-U.S.
BEEN FORCED TO REGISTER AS A
BEEN EVER REQUIRED TO BE DOING
THAT.
WHO WOULD GO ON TO A CHANNEL
LIKE THAT, ONE WHOSE SOLE AGENDA
IS TO DISCREDIT AND DESTROY THET
IS TO DISCREDIT AND DESTROY THEE
AMERICAN EXPERIMENT?
NO ONE OTHER THAN ADAM BENNETT
LEADING MAN OF
THE -- AND YET, ADAM SCHIFF WAS